hello everyone and welcome to
broadcasts cryo-electron microscopy
revolutionizing the world of structural
biology and healthcare
presented by mark storms products
marketing manager life sciences business
unit materials and structural analysis
analytical instruments group
Thermo Fisher Scientific I am Alexis
Krause of laberd's and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lavage and
sponsored by thermo Fisher Scientific
for more information on our sponsor
please visit www.dent.umich.edu/license
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please use
the ask a question box to let us know
that you're having a problem please join
me in welcoming mark storms I will now
turn the presentation over to him thank
you very much Alexis for introducing me
and giving me the opportunity to
introduce you into the world of
cryo-electron microscopy in this
presentation I will cover actually a
number of topics
first of all quickly introduced into
thermo Fisher the role of thermo Fisher
in Lex microscopy and then I will switch
to explaining a little bit what
currently drive structure biology the
complementary technologies that bring
their individual values to the structure
Bureau quick question scientific
questions that people actually face
today I will spend some special
attention on the the latest let's say
lost a couple of years resolution that
cryo-em has gone through and the
recognition that technology basically
has as recognized as actually obtained I
will show some unique applications data
or cryo-em has made a difference I also
talked a little about the unique single
optical workflow concept that thermo
Fisher has developed and also the
challenges that come along with this
this workflow and if you are interested
after hearing my story for that a safety
5%
cover also some slides on how you can
engage into cryo-em what is the best way
to get in contact and a dr. technology
basically and has already introduced the
results of submarine conclusions and Q&A
session at the end of the presentation
first of all a quick introduction into
let's say thermo Fisher the groups and
row actually electron microscopy belongs
to and principle is actually a light
microscopy part of the analytical
instruments group which also includes
equipment like spectroscopy mass spec
and chromatography equipments and this
analytical instruments groups is roughly
representing 22 percent of the total
revenue of 21 billion with in term of
Fisher and with that is actually over
the area that its focus mainly on let's
say ddddd advanced equipment for
analysis and structural biology analysis
Shinda basic question of course is why
is actually structure biology important
and what do we see actually a role
within structure biology in the upcoming
years and the main rationale behind this
this statement is the fact that people
grow older luckily people grow older
obviously but when people were older
that also comes with visible and
invisible chronic diseases elderly
diseases like Alzheimer's or Taylor's
Carosa SAN diabetes and people of course
ideally would like to live long and
happy without too many of those diseases
so to give an indication currently
around 40 million annual deaths actually
are correct from diseases which are
related to actually elderly specific
diseases in order to actually avoid
those diseases from occurring and we
need to understand the fundamentals of
the disease mechanisms much better and
if you say it is it also automatically
means that we have to understand
critical metabolic pathways and it all
comes down to the biochemistry or
molecular biology level of understanding
the building blocks of life
understanding how protein behaves as an
individual protein but also as a protein
which interacts as a complex with other
proteins or with DNA or with membranes
or in the context of a cell and if this
is understood then it can also play a
role in the development of new drugs and
more efficient drugs in general and
that's basically the driver between
current research in in structural
biology if we talk about structure
reality there are actually a lot of
technologies that play a role here or
actually form part of the structure
biology technology base so to speak the
Criterium is one of them and I will talk
in detail about maybe the most important
application right now which is called
single particle cryo TM but also
cryo-electron tomography will emerge as
a equally important ology within now in
a couple of years time but also NMR very
classical technology and x-ray
crystallography are very very important
ologies next to x-ray microscopy and of
course light microscopy basically they
have their own scale in the landscape of
technologies and as Roger Kornberg
rightfully said each technology brings
something
both to the table and the combination of
the technologies make this cermak's Li
most powerful so it's all about
complementary technology it's not that
criteria necessary will replace some of
these technologies everything as a piece
of the puzzle in this respect what is
this piece of the puzzle and so respect
you can say the same of course about the
workflow from the basics of life the
genome towards the fool you embody did
let's say the large volume analysis or
the cell or tissue biology everything
started course with the genes the
genomics the translation of the human
genome project for example into various
proteins that are expressed by these
genomes currently where are the stages
of exploring the shape and the function
of these individual proteins and how
they respond if they interact with each
other in cell for example in this
specific disease case and this is
require am single particle analysis
kicks in it is obviously very important
that the information that is revealed by
performing crystallography and
performing criterium single particle
analysis is positions translated into
the cellular context obviously it's
interesting to look at one individual
protein complex but it's only functional
when you look at it in the context of
yourself and that's actually requiring
tomography book again the transposition
of high molecular structure biology
information day by spa and
crystallography into the cellular
context and ultimately of course that is
also the same stories proof it into
itself into a tissue into an organ and
do total body for now actually in this
presentation again I will focus on what
I mention rated single particle analysis
that the technology actually has become
as you know very well recognized the
last couple of years has already become
clear if most people have read
literature in 2015 single particle
analysis was actually water this method
of the year mainly because of what is
called the resolution revolution the
sudden increase in obtained resolution
of proteins and protein complexes due to
some very
differentiating technologies which I
will get back to later on and this year
actually actually the aim of last year I
should say the Nobel Prize of Chemistry
was awarded for the pioneers in cryo
lacta microscopy being charcter Busha
mainly focused on sample preparation and
I will talk about a little bit more in
the next couple of slides Richard
Henderson was the first to really
acquire
remember it's really image of a protein
atomic resolution and a lot of
development on detectors as well and I
owe him Frank who is basically playing a
role at the backside of the single
particle workflow the image processing
party was the one who helped among
things algorithms that make possible for
fuzzy images cry images to turn or to 3d
reconstruction so the technology is
really yeah you can say well recognized
and there are few technological reasons
basically for this ya resolution if you
like to call it that way and a couple of
these technologies have been invented or
Co enabled also by thermo Fisher and Fei
it's basically predecessor the most
important want to mention are the direct
electron detectors detectors which have
an extremely high sensitivity which have
actually decay politi to look at very
low electron dose image information
which makes it actually possible to look
at very sensitive material at the
maximum possible resolutions but also
the platform and the acquisition and the
automation is very important as we'll
show you the next couple of slides when
I explain the principle of single
particle analysis it is a highly
automated process and the less and less
manual interference is needed actually
in this case and development of specific
software it also plays a crucial role
near allows would at least of course is
all about the reconstruction so for a
lot of academic institutions have
developed various software packages for
reconstruction of single particle
acquired datasets and turn them into 3d
reconstruction I think the subset of all
these technology breakthroughs have made
it possible to also create a scientific
impact actually on the community and
also gave a few examples of death as
structure to function analysis a better
understanding of actually disease
mechanisms but also even target drug
discovery is known the exploratory phase
thanks to basically the technology
breaks users are just introduced and
obviously as already said there are
complementary technologies like X or D
animal they have actually long history
log tradition already played a crucial
role models of data in the protein
database obtained by using Exedy NMR but
there is actually an interesting sweet
spot or cryo-em fits in actually with
currently let's say want to reveal what
cryo-em stands in terms of the
achievements then you can basically if
you want to simplify the entire story
say the best possible resolution that
has currently been obtained by doing
cryo a and single-particle alice's is
already sub 2 angstroms 1.8 actually
slightly better already 1.5 into that
direction scientists already have gone
with specific samples you can see
individual water molecules for example
and aromatic rings and side chains
already this resolution extremely good
but all the capability of cryo you have
to look through large membrane protein
complexes and really extreme large
membrane protein complexes like this
example on this slide the rest periods
of complex of 1.7 mega Dalton's which
consists of 81 proteins in the complex
that's really unique for cryo-em trial
an x-ray crystallography is in this
respect not capable of crystallizing
dead large portions of proteins in a
complex manner and this is also were
actually crying makes a difference and
but also very small proteins can be
analyzed to a couple of years ago five
ten years ago cryo veamos valuable if
you would look to steady state
structures large structures like viruses
and make it all the complexes but
there's a lot of course science into
this smaller protein complexes into
smaller proteins in general sub 250 kilo
daltons and even support on a kilo
dalton proteins and thanks to another
technology breakthrough the faceplates
there's also been compostable for small
proteins to be visualized and this
example is of a 64 kilo dalton a mocha
pine protein so to summarize it
resolution gets better proteins get
larger those two complexity that can be
revealed but also on the other hand
proteins can get extremely small and
still being able to be imaged at high
resolutions if you would look to and
that's more that's confirming my
previous message to the protein database
for example then a lot of structures
probably more than 90 percent of all the
structures and their 85 percent it has
been
by x-ray crystallography and nuclear
magnetic resonance the two auto
techniques that are introduced already
in my presentation previously but those
technologies have one let's say
limitation they look to the building
blocks of life they can analyze the
building blocks of a protein the monomer
or diametric structures whereas the real
scientific interest is in looking to
large protein complexes because they
gain new biological insights and
standing our protein complex words is
understanding let's say real life in the
context of the cell and it also means
new biological insights and this is a
sweet spot where I am nicely fits in
brought a lot of publications that you
currently see in reality is focused on
so just to give you three examples of
cases where proteins actually or
actually cryo-em has played a crucial
role recently you know many more
examples but I just picked three of them
randomly the study of let's say dynamics
by doing cryo a.m. you can capture
various isolated states of protein and
turn them into information that reveals
something run dynamics on the other hand
already mentioned that complexes that's
really what evaluates of criterium you
can look to large protein complexes and
also short time the result is an
important argument in some cases cryo-em
can really be much faster than the
alternative technologies and also give
you an example on that one the first
example is an example from the
publication in science from let's say
early let's say one a year ago roughly
and it's about a protein a TM protein
that plays a role in man say repairing
DNA that is damaged by all kinds of for
all kinds of reasons locally we have the
DNA repair mechanism otherwise you could
trigger all kinds of mutations and maybe
even cancer now it's important to
understand how this ATM protein this DNA
repair protein works and we know from
analysis by cryo am that there is a kind
of switch a molecular switch which which
is a protein on and off into an active
in a to an inactive state while
understanding is molecular switches of
course very important because it can it
reveal something on the fundamentals of
life and they can also create insight
into a dynamic set good control
to the production of more efficient
drugs against cancer for example but
that's actually the rationale behind
it's dis research and thanks to iam
basically the next level of information
could be revealed
similar story but on a different leak
it's true for looking too with this the
tau protein filament a grinning man ISM
of which plays rolled your Alzheimer's
disease like a lot of similar type of
diseases Alzheimer's is also
characterized by right by creating the
last protein stacks protein filaments
basically which can cause kind of blocks
in the brain in this case and by
analyzing material from a deceased
deceased patients Alzheimer's patients
cry um could do something unique in its
the work of Anthony Fitzpatrick right
recent work last year published in the
in nature we could this thing for the
first time two different types of
filaments that actually are playing a
role in the aggregation process and
aggregation mechanism of this this
plaque formation so understanding what
the building blocks out with a
difference monomeric states are as if
you like of the filaments you can also
actually get a better understanding and
maybe and how these blocks are formed
and how this aggregation process is
formed and understanding how aggregates
are formula brain could maybe lead to a
better understanding on how to design
drugs or maybe even a way to prevent
these aggregates from forming these are
only tiny steps with important steps and
the basic block you can say has been
refused by performing a lecture
microscopy in this case
not example it's the last one for now
that I will share is the Zika outbreak
everybody of course is well what
happened in 2015-2016 terrible disease
with a lot of serious consequences for
for embryonic a young young babies and
children the best way of course is to
make sure that you develop a vaccine
against Zika and hopefully the problem
can be can be solved and for developing
a vaccine again it's also important that
you understand how the virus structure
looks like from the outside so again a
better understanding of various monomer
and dimeric structures in this case
diameter structures of this of the virus
while the individual E and M structures
were known by crystallography that was
already revealed but the overall complex
organization was not known yet and by
performing cryo BM that could also be
revealed and that is actually lab 2 in
2016 to revealing the first virus
publication structure already at 3.8
angstrom resolution that was really
quite decent to start evaluating and
experimenting with the first vaccines
and that happened at the end of the year
first vaccine testing and the phase 2
trial testing is already since March of
last year ready in in the progress so
thanks to cryo you can say that the the
process of developing a vaccine has been
accelerated and hopefully when the next
outbreak of Zika is there is actually a
final solution for it and similarly if
cost are more stories along the same
lines of what I mentioned here may be
with respect to Ebola may be with
respect to HIV
cryo-em really actually from an
amplification point if you show with the
other this capability the needle of
shifting the boundaries of knowledge
why is karate I'm so important from
let's say an experimental point of view
why is it not very interesting compared
to the authority technologies which
definitely also still have a lot of
value and still use the laws one
important example is when you do
criterium the word learn its assets
you're verifying your cry of fixing
actually the samples and cryo fixation
is extremely important because it gives
you the best possible structural
preservation if you do this in another
way by using chemical fixatives there's
a high chance of creating all kinds of
health effects and you want to really
look to reality in the most accurate
state as possible and this is really
difficult later rolling tacitly which is
also an example if you do criterium
there's no need to first crystal create
a crystal or do it isotopic labeling and
like you need to for NMR in principle
it's just just a matter of getting the
protein purified into the proper proper
concentration and then fit refine by
using liquid each and a protein so it's
a little bit easier on paper at least
because you miss part of the complex
crystallization and labeling process and
in general you need only very little
lost advantage little Allah quits of
material so a few microliters actually
even nano leaders of suspension or
principle already enough to perform
cranium that makes it actually very very
attractive and the next actually part of
the presentation I will show the video
by a research fellow in Sweden recently
adopted Khurana VM and I would like to
ask my moderator to start the video and
see what he has to say here
[Music]
the overall scope of our work covers
processes related to gene expression in
organelles such as mitochondria and
plastids this includes fundamental
questions such as how proteins are
synthesized folded and assembled into
macro molecule functional complexes it
also include the investigation of
evolutionary forces driving the
development of gene expression and
another fold of our work is the
investigation of the medical aspect of
how gene expression can be
therapeutically targeted and finally we
also welcome bioenergetics abilities
questions such as sunlight driven light
conversion which is also weaved to gene
expression in cloudbursts where'd West's
questions with structural biology which
allows direct visualization of cellular
mechanisms and therefore provides the
most efficient way to reveal molecular
basis specifically we employ electron
microscopy where biological samples are
flash frozen fast enough to preserve the
negative state which allows
investigation of the structure in the
context of the cellular function and
we're very privileged here the cryin web
to have access to the most advanced
technology that allows visualization of
molecules up to atomic resolution but
beyond the high resolution perhaps the
greatest advantage of cryo-em
is the identification of multiple
proteins as well as multiple protein
conformation from a single specimen
so that it will allow us to record a
movie of molecules as they perform the
cellular function this can be then
extrapolated to medical applications
we're recording structures and reactions
in the presence of therapeutic compounds
now the world of molecules is beautiful
to look at but it's even more beautiful
to be able to understand it and what is
particularly challenging in our work is
to interpret the molecular structures
into biologically meaningful information
this part is also the most fascinating
as it's really like solving a jigsaw
puzzle where we are trying to assemble
structural elements together into one
single image and during this process you
have the feeling that you are the first
person to reveal these molecular
structures and there is no more
beautiful and rewarding feeling for
structural biologists and to see how
molecules are sculptured by fundamental
laws of biochemistry and this
information is universal because in
biology this is as definitive
it can be it can belt me to do research
and to lead a research group if the part
from the curiosity of course is to watch
how people developing and maturing into
scientists how they advancing
professionally and personally is with at
work and
you
you
so that's actually I think the clear
story on one of the Christmas that
actually has adopted cryo-em
for very obvious reasons now the next
part of the story we'll talk a little
bit about cryo-em and its workflow the
specific technological steps if you like
and what are the challenges in order to
get let's say these challenges overcome
the first slide actually shows the
process of single particle analysis and
what actually you will see in the movie
in the next actually minute again is the
process from by chemistry part putting a
sample onto a grid which is actually
sample carrier that you put into the
microscope once you go to the microscope
after having vitrified examples you
acquire a number of noisy 2d projection
images and you try from those images to
select those particles of which have
various orientations average those
orientations and by averaging and
basically summarizing them if you like
you get a refined 3d model and again I
would like to ask your moderator to
start the video on the workflow for
single particle analysis
you
so that was actually nice animation on
the on single-particle
so what happens if it would digest
actually the various or put the various
sections into perspective and you
started by chemical components for your
purified example as I said then you try
to vitrify this the suspension that you
would like to investigate by using the
facial bolt then it's quite often there
is a step and I will toggle a bit more
onto that of optimization needs where
you look to the protein distribution but
also the thickness of the ice instead of
the proper quality to really do the
analysis any data acquisition in the end
though the process although it looks
actually pretty nice and it is actually
very nice process there are still
actually very critical part of the
workflow which need to be taken into
account and our quickly in the next
couple of slides tackle those individual
parts the first challenge is get the
best of the quality after that is
important to minimize the time on sample
preparation and sample optimization
because you want to go as fast as
possible to the microscope where you do
the final analysis preferably at the
resolution that is needed to answer your
scientific question and it can be
anything let's say in general something
below three angstrom is sufficient to
answer most scientific questions the
first part of get the best sample
quality are actually a few crucial
components that are important and should
be taken into account on the on the
first part by chemistry part it's
obviously important that the protein is
expressed to sufficient levels in order
to purify it once you have these
efficient levels you need to purify the
protein get it clean enough make sure
that you get a to sufficient
concentration levels that is also stable
that the proteins do not fall apart for
example and ideally if your isolate
various fractions of various states of a
protein you would need also to capture
all these states within this purified
fraction that's of course a job on its
own but suppose you get to the right to
the right stage to the right
concentration then the next phase is to
do the pacification and if it's vocation
is something that has been automated
that's in the last 10-15 years various
certification devices have been
developed one of them is the vit robot
and there are a few more which kind of
remove the critical parameters that
determine the variations of the right
ice quality you would like to get
repeated if I scroll of the every time
you do the certification step and it
means repeats different this case that
the ice quality that you obtain when you
plunge freeze your sample into liquid
ether and and liquid propane that needs
to be the right constant thickness but
also the ice quality is very important
needs to be icosahedral ice needs to be
the best ice quality amorphous ice it
should not be hexagonal or cubic lines
and last but at least it will be
possible to look to the various
particles in the proper orientations
because in the end you need to get all
these orientations nicely classified and
averaged so there are still quite some
challenges despite the fact that some
exempt process has been automated at
least if it's vacation part there's
still a lot of challenges to get from
the optin biochemistry into the frozen
hydrated sample to the microscope but
suppose you get there and of course this
is something that is already pretty
routinely right now but still it could
be better in the end you would like to
have a look to the quality of the sample
into the microscope you would like to
see what the part of the aggregation is
for example what the concentration of
the particle is well this is what we
call screening and currently screening
is a crucial part of the single particle
workflow how you do this the various way
to do it typically one of the steps of
people apply a lot is by using a piece
of the sample apply a heavy metal stain
to it which we call negative staining
and by looking to the heavy metal
contrast in the microscope typically
smaller microscope with towers are 120
for example another one on 20 gave you
microscope gives you the information
about the protein aggregation or the
particle distribution if that turns out
to be good then another screening can be
done under dry conditions where you also
look at the same parameters but in
addition to that you also look to the
quality of the eyes again it needs to be
amorphous but also through the thickness
of the eyes this screening process is
trial and error process in general you
can be lucky by getting directly to the
optimal stage and then directly go to
the data acquisition part which you then
can do on either Glacius mic
Bojan shortly introduce afterwards
over-tighten crying but it can also take
it a bit longer depending on how good
your biochemistry is it takes faster or
longer in order to get to the real
acquisition state so important is the
more efficient your screening is and the
more efficient your your sample
preparation is the shorter the time to
sample optimization is second phase and
this would a collectivity plays an
important role once you have done a
proper screening on one of the
microscopes ideally and sometimes not
always but sometimes you would like to
use the same sample or batch of samples
and put them into the microscope where
you want to go for example for high
resolution but that is important that
the same sample can be connected to the
microscope without any contamination
that you can capture in the error and
this is what we call contamination free
samples and so there are two important
key steps in the first phase of the
workflow it's the sample preparation
quality and it's the connectivity
between the screening device and the
open microscope device now for the
screening job we have introduced the
microscope last year which is called the
glaciers the glaciers rotor itself it
has something to do with glaciers with
ice and there's also what it does first
of all it's designed to analyze the
quality of the ice ever mentioned before
ice thickness and quality of the ice but
it also actually allows you to obtain
reasonably good resolutions good racket
that we have is already 2.5 to put 6
angstrom only improving on that so this
is a two hundred kilovolts cope fact tip
for those who are actually expressed on
microscopy it has an outer loader to
load samples to load multiple samples
actually at the same time in a
microscope and also efficiently screen
those samples and select a proper sample
for further analysis you can order
advantageous microscopes the glaciers is
pretty small it's not a very high
microscope so it also fits relatively
easy in too many lap rooms
now this is just one result what are the
first results we obtained on the
glaciers on April ferret understand
example the figures here you see in the
left side a difficult nosy crier image
of particles which looks nicely
distributed in general at a good
contribute and concentration second
picture shows the classifieds or the
average particles of the same
orientation which are basically add up
and multiplies so you see much more
information in noises slowly
disappearing and at the right side you
see the colorful 3d reconstruction of
the protein in this case at frequency
angstrom but we are already now at 2.5
angstrom by using the same instruments
in some principle where the glaciers
beside screening you can get two
resolutions of 2.5 2.6 angstrom in the
tune or thanks for range within a few
days using x indications below in in
this line so as I mentioned this
conductivity is really something which
is very important and also the
microscopes that term official buys and
sorry builds and designs are made in
situate that the conductivity is also
optimized so we have a special grid and
in the sample preparation part on the
vegetables you see that we have created
some sample carrier which is put into a
ring you can say that's what we call the
outer cut ring this outward ring is
loaded until we get set and the cassette
actually can be transported in what we
call a capsule covered in liquid
nitrogen to one microscope the glaciers
so the outer loader and the outer loaded
components which is the grid they
basically ensure the optimal mechanical
connectivity from the screening
microscope to if needed the high
resolution microscope so in case you get
to a good sample and you would like to
push the resolution beyond 2 to another
angstrom level let's say the direction
of 2 angstrom for example in that case
you need to go to it centralized service
facility or to your own Titan price
instruments and then you can simply take
the nano cap with the samples and put
them onto the microscope so there's one
conductivity component mechanical
conductivity component which allows you
to do free
contamination free connection of the
samples second conductivity component is
the software there is also single
particle acquisition software which
allows you to acquire data to facilitate
the screening process and to select
those areas of the grid which are useful
to do further processing and all the
microscopes that term official designs
have the same software so we ensure by
having this philosophy both for our
hardware and for software connectivity
optimization step by having the software
am I having me out to load already to
optimize the workflow process here
talking about this high resolution
microscope we call this the Criers
the christ' d3 is our latest model and
the Christ g3 I actually it's the next
evolutionary face in the outer loader
based criterion microscopy it allows you
to load to ourselves at the same time
thanks to the outer loader we can do
better screening here and we can easily
say use the instruments of a lot of
automated software into the system right
now but also optically wise this
microscope is capable of easily cheaper
solutions better than 3 angstroms and
routinely as I'll show the next slide
two and a half two angstroms and even
better beyond that that's not
unrealistic depending on how the sample
actually has been isolated and the type
of samples heat affinity of the sample
place also important role here
and again an example for also April fair
attendance or standards actually use
case example that this case taken on a
Titan crisis is done with a falcon three
electron detector I mentioned the
electron detectors in the beginning of
my presentation this is actually the
detector that turbo Fisher is developing
the Falcon 3 electron counting tied
together with the Falcon with a cry see
three actually gets a to put two
angstrom which as I mentioned the
beginning for presentation routinely to
an advanced room can be obtained
depending on the sample of course that
the world's record is around 1.5 is one
point eight angstroms already so
optically the Criers is goes actually
one step beyond the performance at least
right now of the 200 kilos of excesses
in general well if you know after
hearing this story have become
interested in in cryo Yama's technology
and you wonder how can I engage how can
I adopt to this new type of experiments
and new type of application then yet are
various way to do is do it you can team
up with an academic partner that happens
to to do already cry in for some time
you can happen to go to the service
facility centralized service facility or
more more synchrotrons currently that
have adopted and purchased microscopes
in order to obtain data that can be used
for reconstruction of data
which you can of course also buy your
own toolset and basically there are two
different configuration flavors that you
can that you can obtain and you would
advisably need a specification device
like a fit robot to do the essential
vitrification and fixation of the sample
iglesias for sample optimization
screening with me advisable and
budgetary wise it is possible and you
would definitely need it also to push
the to the highest possible resolutions
the Titan cries would be nice package
then you ensure the total conductivity
of the tool suite suite of instruments
that the diversification is cleaning and
the acquisition itself if you would
actually require the expertise in order
to get acquainted to cryo-em thermo
Fisher has taken an initiative to
develop what we call accelerate packages
to remember ease flavors of accelerate
packages and I will talk a little about
it in the last part of my presentation
within the next three slides but that
basically allows you to make a quick
start into a new technology and to get
to a high productivity ready in a pretty
short timeframe
that's actually one approach that you
can go that's basically the full suite
approach doors actually maybe even a
more attractive approach to start with
and that is actually that you focus on
investing into a visible in a glacial
that's probably much more attractive
from a pricing point of view the
glaciers as I mentioned is possible
capable of screening very efficiently so
you can find your optimal sample but
also the glaciers is capable of getting
to the desired resolutions if your
resolution is a 2.5 angstrom range and
not better than that so depending on
your scientific case that could be good
enough and then if needed you could go
to a centralized service facility if you
would happen to go to Titan trials that
would then be the next phase but
in-house you could basically start your
own place your switchable combination
there as a novel approach and that you
could use in adopting the technology and
basically it's actually the philosophy
of turbo Fisher to have as many glaciers
as an Arctic gas tiles the same
instrument and to
that is next to it to across the crisis
of course an incident that that is rent
quite often 24/7 you want to use it to
the maximum in a maximum optimal state
that means you want to lose for
acquiring high-resolution images and
Iglesias is a kind of feeder tool into
the tight employers so you would like to
have a glaze yours to optimize your
sample isolate the sample and then go to
the item price virtualization and all
right this slide shows a lot of that
centralized facility or cryo-em
facilities in general at university to
institutes to europe asia in the US
where you have those instruments where
you get connected to so the process of
linking yourself to an academic partner
is very well suitable there's a high
footprint actually of instruments
currently in the field
the last part I would like to talk about
I mentioned it already on one of my my
previous life
it's actually the accelerate packages so
as more people want to engage into crime
microscopy it's also important to to
arrange for sufficient support to make
sure the people can get trained in an
official and an optimal way so we
basically have defined what we call a
customer success management strategy
which contains of a number of components
besides a site survey portfolio an IT
support portfolio that helps you to
analyze your laboratory space where you
would like to position your microscope
we also have taken initiative to to the
star together with a few academic
partners cryo-em schools which actually
are very intense goals four-week
practical and theoretical training
courses held in the United States and
Europe and will also be held in Asia and
future supported by an online trading
guidance which gives you in the end a
certified exam or proof that you
actually are capable of running an
electron microscope the entire workflow
is covered at those criterium schools
from sample preparation all the way up
to data reconstruction so that's
actually what you can do in order to get
educated and the advice we can get
basically to start with in with the
cryo-em experiment an adventure besides
them we've also started what I already
mentioned at the cryo-em accelerate
portfolio package suite and this
contains six different and new features
that can help you to get more acquainted
with the technology it contains of what
we call a workload validation test this
is basically a test that we perform
together with our experts in the field
to show on a real biological sample on
your microscope that high resolution
data can be obtained and we use April
ferritin for that as an example I show
that sample already two times before in
my presentation because also a number
set of hours that you can ask for
on-site application supports people
experts from the nanopores in Hanko
overall the United States they can visit
you and train you for a couple of months
or weeks depending on how much training
you need this is all flexible and can be
determined and tuned and to your
personal needs
it was obviously remote application
support where you can get for offline
support talking directly to one of our
experts or to service one of the real
new things that we have done is the
workflow app to work drive is actually
kind of best known methods guide it's a
very nice interactive app which you can
run on your iPad and a base on your
tablet and you can look through all the
individual processes starting from
vitrification all the way up to the the
processing pause if you have specific
questions you can really look at those
questions up you can ask those questions
into the app and we try to actually do
mature the learning experience that you
can get from the work based on your own
feedback so it's really interactive to
that extent and very useful our users
find only one of the new things that we
have done is what we call the d2i or the
system monitoring all the microscopes in
the fields can be hooked up to let's say
a system which can pre actively monitor
the performance of all the microscopes
and we can also service can also see
which microscopes are performing
properly which microscopes need some
repair activity which microscopes need
some preventive service activity that is
all possible sensors from our system
monitoring so the advantage is that you
can minimize the risk of certain
downtime of the system because we can do
kind of preventive maintenance thanks to
looking into the system that you're
using and often at least those dedicated
quarterly review service between you and
our service organization or our customer
success manager which tells you exactly
you have the statistics on the use of
your microscope and also were things
could potentially be improved so
basically we take you by the hand that's
actually the message here by introducing
this curse from success management
strategy in the accelerate portfolio
rolling out to make you more successful
and especially for new users I think
that's a pretty pretty useful exercise
to do
well that brings me to my my last slides
in summary and if you can summarize
actually work Timofey sure as an
organization actually it is actually
currently at in terms of cryo-em
i think we can say that the quraíam in
general has improved technology it's
also recognized the technology i
mentioned that nobel prize matter of the
year but also if you look to the output
that most of official microscopes
generate and the last portion of the
output of the invited Titan clients and
its predecessors like the Polana and
also the Arctic are more than thousand
structures are currently deposited and
I'm talking about 2017 data here based
on thermo Fisher microscopy data and
increasing the number of cryo-em data in
the protein database is significantly
increasing and probably from absolute
numbers as the fastest growing rate in
drone base here and there are a
significant amount of publications and
also here it is also increasing and
based on prime M data there is work for
connectivity that has an advantage we
have a huge install base in the fields a
lot of Korea's microscopes Dallas
Arctica microscopes and also glacial
systems which you introduce are getting
installed into the field that means that
we have a optimal productivity and
density to do the screening and go to
any other microscopy fields for your
optimal resolution performance for
example the connectivity I mentioned
that is ensured by on one hand the
software which allows you to do the
screening in optimal way acquire the
optimal datasets and loads parameters
and coordinates from one market to
another that's office capable of and on
the mechanical side we have the outer
order in the outer grids which allows
you also to switch from one microscope
and to another
and of course introducing research in
microscope and having such a large
database and also introduced the
accelerate packages requires a lot of
support troops into the field and that's
also what we currently have we have more
than one on 65 crying and service and
application specialists that take care
of the maintenance preventive
maintenance and also of the the
application support and also the
critérium skills obviously and yeah last
but not least there are multiple ways to
start crying if you're interested I just
give you a few examples the full suite
option that lets say the startups option
the productivity with a scientific
colleague or with a centralized service
facility everything is possible and
these days not to get engaged with the
technology I would like to also refer to
our website in this particular request
most information that I've told you
about this also on a website and if you
have more information after visiting a
website then please contact me of one of
my colleagues from the sales or business
development Club and with that I would
like to thank you for your attention and
I'm happy to answer questions if the
Reilly questions thank you
Thank You Marc for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left to
your presentation let go type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for so let's get started
our first question is do you expect that
cryo-em
will replace expert x-ray
crystallography in NMR
good question I don't expect that this
will be the case as I mentioned in the
beginning of a presentation every
technology has a specific place specific
niche in the spectrum of structure
biology techniques cryo-em is very
useful where it comes down to looking to
protein complexes large molecular
assemblies whereas X or D is very good
and dedicated to look to the building
blocks of life and a tomorrow probably
into the flexible domain so ya know it
will not replace it
cryo ml I think very nice complementary
addition to the existing technologies
how can we accelerate support packages
be ordered and the accelerate support
packages can be ordered actually via the
regular sales process so if you contact
your local cop manager then yeah they
can help you actually part of the the
configuration package that I explained
this is full suite and the let's say
start up sweet package to have it
included and depending on your expertise
level you know I would recommend to at
this we have three different flavors of
accelerate so let's say the light
accelerate package the more intense
seller is accelerate package where you
get more support basically and you know
then the maximum support package or you
also have a lot of on site and telephone
support so you're the best ways to to
orbit via your account manager that's a
short answer
okay mark what is the expected
resolution performance of the Glacia
yeah the glaciers pretty new so we
actually first were not sure what the
resolution target was but we see now
what a shoulder presentation was
resolution 3.2 3.3 angstrom but recent
experiments that we did in an airport
has pointed out the resolution of 2.6
angstroms so we're really getting to
where yeah do the do the sweet spot of
of the resolution I think for a lot of
scientific use cases 2.6 angstrom is
probably also sufficient again if you
want to push the resolution
scientifically and was the levels into
angstrom range then probably three-
exits unlike the titan crisis needed but
the glaciers or tuna Cavey [ __ ] in
general probably what gets you at 2.5
Hanks resolution
and our next question is are there any
tools or regions on the sample prep side
of things that could help improve the
workflow
yes so the if you talk about the sample
prep side of things then currently what
we have to help there as the the vit
robot is actually I would say well
establish instrument have also proven
value think we have more than done six
sort of it robots in the meantime in the
field of course there were these things
that that can also be improved on the
respective hit robots so it's a thing
especially with respect to the
connectivity of the sample preparation
general and loading the sample into the
microscope there's still room for
improvement and what also actually is an
interesting topic of discussion curly in
the field is the grid carrier so that is
actually related to the material you put
your sample on depending on the material
you can get actually better distribution
of your particles and a lot of research
is also currently done in the into depth
field so it's not only the VESA fication
but also again how can we equally
distribute the particles in a verified
section and the self carry can play a
crucial role there as well and that's
currently on the research basically
XRD requires about 10 milligrams of
protein for screening but how much does
cryo am require yeah I would say a
concentration of 10 milligrams per
milliliter oh that's a good
concentration also in general for cryo
a.m. depends a little bit on the type of
type material that you begin to with any
concentration between 10 milligram per
milliliter it's also what is typically
used or these advised for for chromium
so there is actually a similarity net
respect but luckily you don't need to to
crystallize your sample so it's just
purified fraction of this concentration
it's sufficient to start a
beautification process
and if there are no more questions
mark I would like to once again thank
mark for his presentation mark would you
like to make any final comments
now I hope it was useful to you as I
said RM if you want to learn more about
cryo a.m. please visit our website or
come to one of our colleagues and we are
happy to to help you out and provide you
with more information thank you for your
attention
I would also like to thank Thermo Fisher
Scientific for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May of 2019
please share that message with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event also stay tuned for our next
presentation introduction to the labcoat
live smart start training courses for XP
protein expression system presented by
Stephanie Culbertson you won't want to
miss it that's all for now thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you again
soon goodbye
you